8h du matin métro beaubien
valérie plantes qui n'habite pas très
loin parce nous prendre dans sa voiture
de fonction dans la plainte
oui faut savoir qu'avec moi oui merci
beaucoup
et oui c'est une bonne journée pour
limoux elles quitteront le vélo et le
transport en commun n'a jamais autant
utilisé la voiture en 22 ans m'ont rien
c'est paradoxal parce que j'ai trop de
récupération dans une journée
est-ce que c'est plus difficile que vous
auriez imaginer à
non c'est pas plus difficile j'aimerais
que ça mandela beaucoup d'adaptation
entre autres parce que je t'aime maman
j'ai deux ados et mon job sa job c'est
lui le parent d'un numéro 1 avant
c'était moi
si la maintenance et puis moi qu'est ce
que c'est important de prendre part
parfum de sa mère en général j'ai au
moins une journée où là
c'est relax à la maison
[Musique]
avec son rire contagieux on l'entend
quand elle arrive quelque part ce matin
elle est au palais des congrès pour
prononcer un discours devant le montréal
des affaires dernières mises au point
avec son équipe
valérie planté fébrile mais en parfait
contrôle une de mes forces à moi c'est
l'énergie
la meilleure façon de communiquer sauf
ses quinze bougies linge par baril
elle présente la stratégie économique de
son administration
l'économie qui n'est pas perçue comme la
force de projet montréal
alors on veut vous en tant qu on veut
être capable de vous soutenir elle nous
vante le bilan de sa première année sont
partis dit-elle ait et innovateur
comment on veut développer et
territoires par exemple s de montréal
comment est-ce qu'on veut plus proactifs
avec les commerces ont entravé faire un
plan commerce de l'eau a émané notre
programme pour soutenir les commerçants
lorsque des artères en chantier dont la
salle valérie plantes semblent apprécier
elle sert des mains et on la prend en
photo mais en coulisses certains se
disent partagé par le premier bilan
économique de son administration
le reproche est souvent que les
décisions sont trop longues apprend
bah écoute et j'entends les processus on
va les accélérer on essaie de toujours
plus agile mais existent quand on doit
être je dois je suis redevable envers la
population également dans la décision
que sa décision la plus controversée a
été la hausse des taxes sur l'eau pour
renflouer les coffres de la ville dédiée
aux infrastructures avec comme résultat
une augmentation moyenne des taxes plus
élevées que l'inflation contrairement à
sa promesse électorale
moi ça m'a permis après saddam dire moi
je fais ce que j'ai besoin de faire même
si c'est pas populaire pour moi ça ça a
été réglé
ceci étant dit pour la taxe sur l'eau on
pouvait pas faire autrement et je
referais la même chose puisque je serai
vraiment différent c'est que l'année
donnant une perspective plus plus
humaine plus valérie oui c'était bien il
me fait la lettre du cths à 9h40 petite
pause café
la mairesse revoit ses notes en vue du
point de presse à venir un peu de
magasinage pour encourager les artisans
locaux présents au palais des congrès
puis c'est le départ vers
l'arrondissement du sud-ouest en route
un chantier nous ralentit les soeurs qui
laisse pas de mobilité et règle pas tout
mais ce qu'on a vu et ce qu'on observe
c'est que l'escouade mobilité réussi à
trouver à trouver des solutions rapides
pour des problèmes qui survenaient
vêtements est ce qu'une promesse en
mobilité dont vous êtes particulièrement
fier mais c'est sûr mais 300 autobus
c'est clair parce qu'il y avait eu un
sous investissement depuis maintenant
dans les autobus qui en manquent par
tout moment par 11h20 valérie plantes
présentent aux journalistes ces deux
candidates aux élections partielles
mais les questions portent rapidement
sur son nouveau bureau de projet de la
ligne rose que françois legault ne
priorise pas qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
marianne en pierre des prairies qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour eux
faut trouver des options plus complet du
cc
quand je sens qu'on recherche quelque
chose on cherche à me faire dire quelque
chose
le présentement on cherche à me faire
dire par exemple que moi puis monsieur
legault on est en chicane qui
s'abonneront malgré ces pôles comme non
pêche
elle promet de se battre pour sa ligne
rouge la question de la mobilité doit
mercredi encore les deux studios de fox
en début d'après-midi elle mange dans
son bureau de l'hôtel de ville tout en
préparant avec ses proches conseillers
une mission économique qui aura lieu
dans douze jours en californie
[Musique]
15h30 c'est le pdg du palais des congrès
khl a rendez vous avec elle pour parler
de son projet d'agrandissement en
campagne les libéraux avaient promis de
le financer
mais pas la cac sauf que les nouvelles
sont encourageantes
la mairesse ensuite un peu de temps pour
elle dans son bureau et elle en profite
pour lire les nouvelles sur son portable
que répond-t-elle à ceux qui lui
reprochent d'empirer les problèmes de
circulation par exemple avec le projet
pilote pour empêcher le transit sur le
mont royal pendant la campagne on a été
très très clair sur cette notre vision
capital on parle d'environnement
toujours cette question look dont tout
le monde semble de plus en plus être
interpellé il ya des gestes qui peuvent
être faits individuellement soit mais
faut c'est avoir des gestes collectif et
d'un code camille aoustin point de vue
de sécurisation puis il y a eu les
pitbulls que son parti a décidé de ne
plus venir de montréal quelques attaques
ont eu lieu cette année du québec comme
vous dites j'ai pris la bonne décision
mais encore une fois ce qui est pas
évident dans ce dépôt l'un qui est très
émotif 1 et avec raison là c'est plus un
peu de dire c'est le football le méchant
c'est comme plus simple à comprendre
c'est facile à expliquer et mais moi je
pense qu'on peut être la sécurité du
public ça passe par tous les types
d'animaux tous les types de chiens elle
a d'ailleurs trouvé quelques chroniques
sur les pitbulls très durs à son endroit
au cours de cette première année elle
admet que certains commentaires dans les
médias ou les réseaux sociaux aux
percées sa carapace mais pour une raison
que j'ignore
d'un coup j'ai dette
et pas seulement la personne qui peut
charger qui ne change pas les choses
mais qu'il a provoqué ça ça me fascine
toujours un peu ça me fait mal c'est sûr
alors vous le savez notre équipe a fait
de l'habitation de priorité une dernière
répétition avec son attachée de presse
en vue de l'annnonce du lendemain et
valérie plante pas pour anjou où elle
participe à la soirée annuelle d'info
crime il est 18h45
le temps pour elle de discuter avec le
gratin policiers de montréal ce soir
elle rentrera à la maison vers 21h juste
à temps pour ce que tu es vos nuits et
ses garçons et demain ça recommencera
son sens du devoir dit elle lui donne
toute son énergie très heureuse à mort
en baisse après un an beaucoup plus
solide
il est vrai que j'ai comme monter
l'everest cette année le taureau puis
j'ai bien aimé j'ai bien l'intention de
profiter de la vue
[Musique]
[Rires]